let's talk about brexit the UK has been
sucked into non-stop political drama
ever since Britain voted to leave the
European Union back in 2016 angry the
Prime Minister is talking nonsense and
now the Brits are going back to the
polls to choose a new government one way
or another we must proceed straight to
an election now anything can happen
but so far the UK is on course to
deliver brexit in the new year but are
all those people who voted to leave the
EU going to get what they wanted why did
they choose brexit anyway
[Music]
there's a whole bunch of reasons why
people voted for brexit in the 2016
referendum but there was only one
question on the ballot should the United
Kingdom remain a member of the European
Union or leave the European Union a
simple choice right well not so much
that's because leaving the EU is
actually a highly technical process the
European Union is a club of 28 countries
with common laws about areas like
security foreign policy and human rights
and it's a trade bloc of rules and
regulations that allows the free
movement of products and people but if
you're a politician talking
technicalities is not gonna win you
votes so this is how the two sides
argued their case the remain campaign
which was known as Britain stronger in
Europe said staying in the EU made
economic sense above all it is about our
economy it will be weaker if we leave
and that is a huge risk to Britain vote
leave campaign to take back control of
Britain's sovereignty saying it was
being undermined by a bureaucratic beast
in Brussels European law is supreme the
European Court of Justice over rules our
Parliament and our courts ultimately
both campaigns were accused of
misleading voters especially leave the
most infamous clabe was put on the side
of the vote leave bus which said we send
350 million pounds a week to the EU
let's spend it on the NHS the National
Health Service instead now this was
highly dis leading the actual figure was
much much smaller but Ramin was found to
have fudged numbers too Britain would be
permanently poorer if we left the
European Union poorer by four thousand
three hundred pounds per household
yep that wasn't quite right either and
again both campaigns were accused of
fear-mongering the levers even had a
label for remains message I think it's
all baloney or project fear ultimately
one of those arguments specifically
taken back control resonated far more
emotionally with people than the
economic arguments of project fear he
has lost the biggest fight of his career
the political earthquake was happening
it is a moment that came as a huge shock
to some as the UK woke up on the 23rd of
June 2016 52% of voters in the UK chose
to leave the EU 48% voted to remain and
how those votes were split across the
country says a lot most people in
England and Wales chose to leave
although capital cities London and
Cardiff chose remain the majority of
Northern Ireland and Scotland also voted
remain old people tended to vote towards
leave again not overwhelmingly and
younger people tended to vote remain
people with a university degree were
more likely to vote for remain people
with fewer educational qualifications
were more likely to vote for leave and
so big divisions across the country
within even families so we know roughly
who voted which way but the why is
harder to define especially among the
levers there's a lot of evidence to
suggest that people were clear on what
they were voting for the difficulty is
what they were voting for varies from
person to person so everyone had
different motives but there is a common
thread here and it's something called
euro scepticism
now euro scepticism is defined as a
political doctrine that advocates
disengagement from the European Union
you'll find it in France Italy and
across the continent here's how it
played out in the UK after the second
world war the UK stood back and watched
as Europe grew closer during the 1950s
by the 60s the UK wanted to join what
was then called the European Economic
Community but France rejected them twice
finally in 1973 the UK became a member
but just two years later the British
government held the very first
referendum on whether to remain part of
the EEC and a majority voters said yes
but ever since then there's been really
quite an uneasy relationship between
Britain
I'm the EU but here's the thing many
people voting leave weren't just
skeptical about the European Union it
was about a wider dissatisfaction
distrust and disapproval they looked at
the people in Brussels and they looked
at the people in Westminster and they
didn't like what they saw they saw them
as out of touch out of touch with what
many British families were feeling for
at least a couple of generations in the
1980s manufacturing in the UK collapsed
and millions of good-paying Union jobs
were lost at the same time Britain
deregulated the banking and finance
sector and it soon grew into the biggest
industry in the country over the next
couple of decades Britain's economy
boomed the income gap through to but
people at the bottom were able to lean
on the UK's strong welfare system shock
and panic evident on the faces of those
on the trading floor then in 2008 the
global financial crisis hit and the
government brought in austerity measures
there were fewer jobs and cuts to social
benefits and for many working-class
people life got harder which brings us
to another factor in the leave vote
immigration in the early noughties there
were various new states that joined the
EU and then obtained free movement
rights so there were a lot of people
from countries like Poland for example
who came to the UK and that had quite a
substantial change obviously some people
think for the better some people think
for the worse to the UK labour market
enter the European refugee crisis in the
summer of 2015
millions of people mostly Syrians
in Greece and Italy to seek asylum
Germany led the way and letting them in
and other countries including the UK
welcomed some refugees but there was
plenty of fear to leave voters
particularly felt that immigration was a
key issue and that they did feel it was
having a negative impact on this country
not just in economic terms but in social
terms political terms cultural terms we
would hear in focus groups for instance
that some leave voters would say it
doesn't feel like a Christian country in
Britain anymore
so all those frustrations about
immigration plus social and economic
changes and euro scepticism set the
stage for brexit but what triggered the
actual referendum that was politics in
2013 a general election was coming up
the UK's Prime Minister David Cameron
worried about losing votes to the
increasingly popular and Euroskeptic UK
Independence Party so Cameron promised
the British people that if his
Conservative Party won he would hold a
referendum on EU membership was it David
Cameron never thought you actually have
to give that referendum and I don't
think he thought he'd win an outright
majority at the next general election
but he did so he had to keep his pledge
Cameron then campaigned to stay in the
EU and thought he would win again and
it's often said that any leader will not
call a referendum unless they think they
can win and David Cameron certainly
thought that it could another political
gamble gone bad for David Cameron and in
the end that referendum became a
lightning rod for decades of built-up
discontent about all sorts of things in
some ways brigs it was an accident
waiting to happen
there's a story or a topic you want to
get your head around get in touch with
us on Twitter or Facebook also make sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel so
you never miss an episode
you